should i play this from the cd or are
you going to do this live
do whatever you want could you do it
live could you do your new song live
yeah we could you remember the words can
i you know i don't know what your
what your vibe is on this radio station
can i say the words
i thought that she could say it we can't
here's my question if i say the word do
you get charged no
no you get charged no no nobody gets
charged yet there is speak about
the artists themselves being charged so
what are you what are you going to use
then
bum-bum you can say a-hole you can say
that you can't say a-hole
a-hole you can say you just can't say
the whole word but is that going to
screw up the cadence of the song
let's think of a good word instead of
a-hole fred what's a good word instead
of a-hole
here's what i'm going to write it down
can we say this one and that's not a
dirty word
let's see what he's talking about i was
wondering about bunghole
i was thinking that too but i thought
that was bad no that's okay i think
because
it's a legitimate work they say that on
beavers and bloodheads
you can say whole but you can't say yes
how about say
[ __ ] wait a second
how about ass bowl unless you want to go
to basshole
all right we'll be quiet and you decide
what you want to say
i can be an ash bowl of
the grandest kind
i think
[Laughter]
we won't look at you you don't look at
us here we go focus on something else
[Music]
i can be an asphalt of
the grandest kind don't look at me
i can withhold like it's going
out of style
i can be the moodiest
baby and you've never met anyone who's
as negative as i
am sometimes
i am the wisest woman you've
ever met i
am the kind of soul with whom you've
connected
i have the bravest heart that you've
ever seen
and you've never met anyone who's
positive
as i am sometimes
you see everything
you see every part
you see all my light
and you love my dark
you dig everything
of which i'm ashamed
there's not anything to
which you can't relate and you're still
here
i blame everyone else not my
own partaking
my passive aggressiveness can be
devastating
i'm terrified and mistrusting
and you've never met anyone who's as
close
down as i am sometimes
you see everything
you see every part
you see all my light
and you love my dark
you dig everything
of which i'm ashamed
there's not anything to
which you can't relate and you're still
here
but i resist persists
and speaks
[Music]
would i resist
you love no matter
how low or high i
go
i'm the funniest woman that you've ever
known i
am the dullest woman that you've ever
known i'm
the most gorgeous woman that you've ever
known
and you've never met anyone who is as
everything as i am
sometimes you see everything
you see every part
you see all my light
and you love my dark
you dig everything
of which i machines
there's not anything to
which you can't relate when you're still
here
you're still here
[Music]
so your boyfriend must be pretty special
[Applause]